today I present unto you an acoustic
version of one of my new chameleon
circuit songs it's called dr. what and I
hope you like it and stuff okay
my girlfriend thinks that I'm a nutter
my parents say that I'm an utter fool
for wasting my time on this but I'm not
chasing my imagination I just can't help
avoid my fixation because I know that he
really exists
if you look through time that you will
find so many artifacts have been signed
with Clues all pointing his way and
though he may have different faces I
think it's him in all the cases the man
is an enigma who knows where he is today
just have a look at what I found and see
am I going crazy or is he following me
you can find his legacy scheduler you
out know the history book so it's time
to leave him out he's called the doctor
but doctor what I think he's a Martian
though I know that that's a long shot
doctor but dogs when now check back to
prehistoric times and there he is again
well that's the doctor the doctor how he
saves the planet all the time but never
stops the Bower mister doctor the doctor
who and most importantly doctor how can
I find you he takes danger with him
everywhere he goes so if he does show up
then we'll know that something's not
right but I just can't help but think
that I would make a good companion by
side I'm pretty brights always polite Oh
doctor take me up tonight I know that I
should get a grip but I need to see
inside a ship and have it take me
everywhere he's gone or at least I'd
like to meet the guy to shake his hand
and say goodbye and thank you for all
stun you can't deny that aliens must be
real well is it that hard to believe
that some might be revealed to look like
us well I know it's just all speculation
but I feel I must try to trust in what I
feel he's fooled the doctor but doctor
what I think he's a Martian though I
know that that's a long shot doctor but
doctor when notic back to prehistoric
times and there he is again while that's
the doctor but doctor how he saves the
planet all the time but never stops the
Bower mr. doctor but doctor who and most
importantly doctor how can I find you I
know that I must seem like some kind of
Neanderthal while you're a flying cosmic
genie is to know it I'm just an insect
there's nothing I can do how could I
expect that I would ever meet you doctor
but doctor what I think he's a Martian
now I know that that's a long shot
doctor but doc sweat now take back to
prehistoric times and there he is again
while that's the doctor but doctor how
he saves the planet all the time but
never stops the Bower mr. doctor but
Doctor Who and most importantly doctor
how can I find you it's time for some
chameleon circuit fun facts did you know
the lineup for Doctor Who band has
recently changed a bit its chameleon
circuit now consists of myself Alex day
Liam Dryden and a brand spanking new
member who calls himself Eddie plant
hmm he's new but he's also really nice
and plays music well so that's good and
stuff so welcome to the band
Edie another fun fact did you know that
as chameleon circuit we're currently
putting together a sort of eagerly
anticipated second album and it's called
still got legs or at least we would be
putting that together right now if our
producer my friend Michael Aranda who
came over from America to produce the
album for us wasn't stuck in France I'll
put some links down in the doobly boo
boo boo do bar so you can find out more
about this situation but basically we
want to make this album what we can and
we will at some point obviously but we
just need to get some stuff sorted out
first but it's coming still got legs
thank you for your continued viewership
to the Charlie cool as you
like whatever it is channel that's nice
of you I love you and you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool